I'm gonna give you guys three numbers a
three number sequence and I have a rule
in mind that these three numbers obey
and I want you to try to figure out what
that rule is but the way that you can
get information is by proposing your own
set of three numbers to which I will say
yes that follows my rule or no it
doesn't follow my role and then you can
propose what you think the rule is that
fair yeah yeah okay so here here are the
three numbers 2 4 8 2 4 8 you don't need
to continue the sequence you can propose
a totally different sequence whatever
you want to propose and I will simply
say yes or no definitely 4 8 16 32 16 32
and 64 there's also follow my rule ok
what's the rule we multiply by 2 that is
not my rule right that's not my rule but
you're allowed if you want propose three
other numbers 3 6 12 3 6 8 12 3 6 12
follows my rule 10 20 40 10 20 40 that
follows the rule there are some
multiplying by 2 and yes it follows my
rule but no it's not my rule 5 10 10 and
20 follows my rule 100 200 400 follows
my rule 500 a thousand two thousand
follows my role I'm gonna keep lying
that's right just keep going you're
totally fine but you're approaching it
the way most people approach it like
think strategically about this you want
information yeah I have information the
point of the three numbers right is to
allow you to figure out what the rule is
yeah okay I'm gonna give you the numbers
that I don't think fits the sequence and
see what you say so I'll say 2 4 7 fits
my rule so whatever I propose is right
so is your rule like you can propose any
number so the rule is anything we say is
yes no but you are on the right track
now hit me with three numbers three six
nine follows my rule
oh that didn't follow my rule this is
good right five ten fifteen that follows
my rule what oh really
yeah I don't believe this one two three
one two three follow the rule what about
seven eight nine follow me yes that
follows the rule eight 1639 fits the
role excellent but where you're no
closer to the rule I want you to get to
the rule about one seven thirteen
follows the rule eleven twelve thirteen
I don't know how to do this does not
follow the rule ten nine eight does not
oh so is it all in ascending order oh
yeah okay up top yes first to get it you
guys nailed it that's the rule that's
the rule
increasing numbers in increasing order
Oh one two three four five six ten
fifteen twenty five doesn't matter any
numbers in ascending order I was
inspired to make this video by the book
the Black Swan by Nassim Taleb now the
Black Swan is a metaphor for the unknown
and the unexpected I mean in the old
world the theory was that all swans were
white so each instance of a white swan
would make you think yeah that theory is
pretty good but the point is you can
never prove a theory true and in fact
when people found Australia they
realized that there were black swans
what was interesting for me was that
everyone I spoke to came up with a rule
very early on and then only proposed
numbers that fit with that rule they
were thinking I was looking for you guys
to propose a set of numbers that didn't
follow your rule and didn't follow my
rule I was looking for you guys not to
try to confirm what you believe you're
always asking something where you expect
the answer to be yes right like you're
trying to get at it yeah but instead you
want to get it the know you want to get
the know because that's much more
informational for you than the yes like
if everything's doing against you say
that that is what's so important about
the scientific method we set out to
disprove our theories and it's when we
can't disprove them that we say this
must be getting at something really true
about
reality so I think we should do that in
all aspects of our lives if you think
that something is true you should try as
hard as you can to disprove it only then
can you really get at the truth and not
fool yourself
you